should have there was there was a point
to what I'm after but after I had to
give up the big one poisoning after I
gave up the bishop with uh with Bishop
before I I don't think I need any
particular grounds to think I'm I'm
better
okay but that I'm not sure what I think
about 3G so this is wouldn't say an old
favorite of mine I just planned but
anyway you got to play something I even
played a few my website to classical
sort of normal at a good position
against my camera onward and hangs
stained it's true or if it's Annihilator
solid game against Kuryakin Andrew was
to take only five but they just assume
that yeah this used to be somewhat
central line of this of mice variation
better Isis LightSquared Bishop ah the
position these days that I think now my
every bar looking at a bit different
yeah seeing that much where this is all
that great but its main life fury over
this line at some point after four
that's my house expect knowledge if you
can call it they're not quite stylish
I don't know Bishop III obviously I won
but it's way a claiming that was
slightly better because of those
something like ninety seven and if you
take Sunday for engrossed and I think I
can even make it take on be seven and
five and the fact of the point of seven
is hanging gives me some I think is
probably going to take I'm not sure
though sorry mom
this is there's nothing I'm not sure
it's it's correct huh I could also go
[ __ ] before but I want this I released
on the roster I was 30 he was gonna
Ashima pretend I have some initiative
here but I want me to really let not
Elizabeth takes takes better like why
why now if it has initiative here and
not him is the very marginally worse
image it's very solid
I mean I can go my default check but if
it goes 94 not sure what I guess I got 7
that's pretty solid worst case I can go
something like takes and then see 6 you
can take only 5 but that's his mantra
kind of center my my king isn't a Sun
Khan's probably still be the best option
I have so you guys for this probably
gonna play Bishop chief buy-in to
prevent him from going lighter 6 here
and 6 by transferring now the question
is whether I'm just in time to to
protect everything but yeah this is this
is obviously it looks like I don't know
black make Muslims like this ever never
might be better I don't know 58 I don't
think he has anything here
I guess wish before instead of 92 and
move for whatever it was for so I would
very much like to transfer the knight to
f6 quite question is whether I'm when
I'm in time where I should just go for
for something this is employer with as
usual this is not but not g6 - were to
have again I should again smugness in
general because he will be enjoying
myself it is easy provoking like not
working a string I just just want to
take anyway if it takes I'm slightly
surprised with maybe it's rookie wife's
he found out good enough I thought and I
believe I'm just better now I thought he
could have done this in a different
fashion yeah I think but I mean even
even this position is actually less like
you place to me yes prophet Jonah yes th
why so many ago I was fine he goes were
g8 mg4 check
so I feel like I already need to do
something so it is very simple to stop
okay I have a choice here whether to
take or just cooking at 5:00 and then
play G for this might not be so horrible
but we're obviously the problem is with
take is that you go very what do you
want or draw here and my king is kind of
cut out cut off from from the pawns but
I don't think I ever have a great choice
once again he surprises me the one thing
I the sensitivity again then King f5
when yeah h4 better mentally
fluorescence
I told myself I should always be my
extra pawn is not greater than control
this mine and I reckon that's one good
thing that I have going for me here I'm
not very far behind on the clock I can
play I hope they work f8 I don't think
he can he can afford to shoot before
check or at least now the point is
obviously work at fourth and work at six
and I have a presumably winning and this
rook that's clever on him before I'm
gonna go King f6 rook I didn't mess that
for and then came t5 and hopefully I
will be able to cover up sticks next
make sense don't see any reason why I
should be bad
yeah this is going to be quite bad I
guess don't think you achieved the whole
line cuz ping g5 here you cannot play
rock of fate or any of the moves I would
like this lonely my riches in the gamin
okay now I have at least half this is
going so great I don't think it's
objectively enough to win but actually
wasn't moved it was just in practice it
may be the side hanging just trying to
improve my piss level and hopefully
setting a little trap which is now which
is not a trap I realize because he had
rook t6 Mother's Day brocade for rooks
e6 then I thought I'd rotate to attend
skinks the rook c5 early by don't
actually I don't actually gain anything
she was checked there in the end which
he was my shitty some hope fairly
miniscule I think obviously intending
Queen came chief for and then the rakesh
change if he goes yeah that was that was
a very large she goes rip Jade but he
doesn't he doesn't have to do that he
can he can wait I have some small
chances still I think but I got a speed
up with a touchpad and everything it's
gonna be very fast tonight the time
scramble this I'm quite happy to see
isn't this just run ena yep during this
one is not going to work out either